Speaker 1: So, OK, Trump does his rally in
Florida.
It's riddled with lies.
It's pathetic.
It's authoritarian.
It's hypocritical.
Fine in the sense that it's what we've come
to expect and what we've come to know.
But understand that without Trump supporters
who are willing to stand around for 12 hours
waiting for the rally and are willing to,
it's not even take in and accept it's there's
not even the possibility that they would question
any of the things that Donald Trump says during
these rallies.
Without those people, there really is no rally.
It's just Trump speaking to an empty room.
So let's look at some Trump supporter interviews
from the rally in Sarasota, Florida.
And this is going to set us up for our conversation
that I'll be having after the break about
why I believe that if Donald Trump does run
in 2024, it's not good at all for the Biden
Harris ticket.
I think Biden Harris are in real trouble.
If Trump runs, we're going to get to that.
OK, but first, Trump supporters, here's one
being interviewed by Real America's Voice.
And check out its we've talked about delusional
before.
This is not just delusional.
This is a sort of defiant and proud delusion
that is different than a lot of what we've
seen prior to the Trump era.
Take a look at this
Speaker 2: reporter, a Trump supporter.
Why are you continuing to support the president
so aggressively and passionately still right
now in twenty, twenty one?
Speaker 1: And this is a key.
Why is this a key question?
I mean, you know, real America's voice, these
people this is all terrible.
But why is this a key question?
Because if we want to figure out what 22 and
24 will likely look like, this is the perfect
question.
Why are you still supporting this guy so aggressively?
He lost everything for you.
He lost 18 and 19.
He lost the house for you in 20.
He lost the White House and the Senate.
Well, but they don't even believe that that's
the key
Speaker 3: because he really won the election.
He loves our country.
He loves our veterans.
Speaker 1: He wants there it is.
There it is uncritically accepting.
There's not even a chance she wouldn't accept
it.
Trump's the Trump the president right now.
That's why I support him.
She says
Speaker 3: safe borders.
And he's our president.
And I just love him because he loves America
so much.
He stands for everything America is and
Speaker 1: understand that this no particular
offense to this woman.
This is just Trump.
Trump, as a privileged New York City born
and raised guy, has spent his life trying
to stay away from women like this woman.
I'm not picking on her in particular.
I mean, it applies to everybody, right?
The workers actually doing the work, building
Trump's real estate projects, the people donating
to Trump's campaign.
All of these people are useful and valuable
to Trump only as far as they can.
They can assist him in whatever his immediate
goals are.
He wants nothing to do with these people.
In reality,
Speaker 3: he's not racist like they say he
is.
And I love him.
That's why I got to I mean, and great people
like you guys that bring us together and tell
us the real truth.
I wish more people were watching and hearing
the real truth.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So there's just not, you know, the language
that's being used that is called language.
That is code language.
And, you know, we've if you want more sort
of texture to understand that language and
these ideologies, check out the interview
I did with Stephen Hacen about Cultish Unnice.
Read the road to Jonestown about Jim Jones
People's Temple.
I'm now reading Going Clear by Lawrence Wright
about Scientology.
It's Trump ism.
That's what it is.
When you when you read it and you then see
these people, that's what it is.
Let's go to another one of these.
This one now is from Newsmax.
These are more interviews with Trump supporters
at the rally
Speaker 4: who love Trump.
I think he's the best thing that happened
to our country and now it's being destroyed.
Speaker 2: What makes you love Trump so much?
Free enterprise system?
You know, it's all about free enterprise system
and the Second Amendment.
And we're all pro FOP's, of course.
Speaker 1: And understand, if you actually
say to these folks, so what did Trump do on
Second Amendment and then what did Biden do
that is so restricting your ability to own
guns, I guarantee you they will not actually
be able to name anything Trump actually did
on firearms.
He actually did very little.
It was mostly rhetoric.
And with Biden, they also will be unable to
name anything.
Now, Biden has tried to do a couple of things.
They're all totally milquetoast, establishing
a commission to study facts and buckling down
a little bit on ghost gun sales, which is
not you know, it's a problem, but it's not
going to restrict, in all likelihood, that
guy's ability to get guns.
It's just made up.
It's there's nothing there.
Speaker 4: Still a lot of great patriots in
this country.
And we're not going to let the left take it
from us.
If this becomes socialism, where in the world
will we go?
Speaker 1: And and again, this is the effectiveness
of propaganda.
What socialism?
What are you talking about?
Give us an I mean, listen, when I when Jesse
Lee Peterson interviewed me, this sort of
prominent, cartoonishly prominent black conservative
and he said, socialism, socialism.
I said, what's one example of socialism under
Obama?
He said, what about those Obama phones?
That's what he was able to come up with.
There's no substance here.
Speaker 4: We want to keep socialism away
from the United States.
Oh, I'm here because the country is not going
in the right direction.
How so?
I will let you know that I was a registered
Democrat since 1976.
Speaker 2: And you tell me a little bit about
your message.
Fight terrorism, support Israel.
Yeah, it's really very simple.
We have a threat from people screaming death
to America, death to Israel, shame group.
Shame, insanity.
Speaker 1: These people are so gross.
Like their support of Israel is just it's
it's disgustingly misplaced.
Speaker 2: And if we don't fight back, we
show our weakness.
I'm here to
Speaker 3: show that people still love him
even when he's so far in retirement.
But we'll see what happens.
Speaker 2: The journey isn't over, is just
beginning.
We have the opportunity to to make America
great again.
We hit a bump in the road.
We got
Speaker 1: an Australian guy apparently loves
Speaker 2: Trump over by the election, by
covid.
But we're going to come back.
We come back stronger than ever.
Why is Trump
Speaker 4: having a rally when there's three
and a half more years until he's he can run?
And I said it's about how it's awesome.
And the vibe here is so great and everybody's
so positive and everybody's so excited.
There is a hope for America.
There's a hope for our future.
Speaker 1: So that is that that is that.
And so after the break, I'm going to explain
to you why I believe if Trump runs in twenty
four, Joe and Carmela are in trouble.
We'll have more clips from this event on our
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman
show.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
See pictures from my recent escapades, which
I'll talk about more on today's bonus show